[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu les yeux quand tu me fais la cour je
le sais depuis le premier jour où tu me
laissera je me lève sera fait dans vos
tous les détours comme la femme et le
[Musique]
mal qui veulent une vie normale
tu voulais
je me laissera je ferais mais le coeur
s'emballe jeu
je me lève
ce
j'y crois malgré le ton
toi tu
on tue
comme toujours
[Musique]
tu es
je n'en sortirait pas indemne je le fais
tout le problème
tu me laisseras tu me le fera mais c'est
que je les ai sur ta faute tu le coach
grandement clash un défaut mais tu me
laisses
tu me le dira
puisque toi il y en aura et à trop jouer
on se crame tu veux
[Musique]
allez saison tu verras tu
tu te feras
je n'ose y croire malgré 3
gros désaccord
mais toi tu viens tu
quelque chose
[Musique]
tu peux
à
[Musique]
cet été
déjà là je me lève
[Musique]
à
sarah
[Musique]
tous les deux
tu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais sera tué
[Applaudissements]